welcome everyone to them
Thursday evening class called viewers
choice so this is a class where club
members I can submit their games also
the people who watch the YouTube videos
they can submit their games via email
preferably PG and format your game and
the email address to send your games is
info at st. Louis
chess club org so this is especially for
our YouTube audience if you haven't
played a game and you know you want to
have the game monetize by grandmasters
submitted at info at st. Louis chess
club org and and possibly your game will
be picked for game analysis so for today
we have couple of games from YouTube
people who sent us but we take a look at
the game of one of the persons who is
here and that is a strong Ashish
reigning is over 2000 right recently
broke two thousand and she's what color
are you are she she's playing white and
this is Ashish here and let's go over
the game and you're playing against 1800
are she she's mm he's playing 1800 so
200 point below go
Hey
okay
before
okay okay
official decent
okay so this is a line if you want to
avoid the main theory main theory you
take back with the Queen on D flow for
okay so this avoids all the main theory
now continue
nice III aha Jesus okay castle
Dawson's bishop Jesus
so this is we have a hey Chuck hey Chuck
setup here also the structure here
okay now black cannot take because the
bishop is unprotected also clean we need
three okay
okay look 81 not fd1 so it is it's
always tricky to realize where you want
to put the rooks here you want to put
the rooks like this or you want to put
it like this and here it's really really
hard to to say at the moment you know
hard to tell you know which way is the
best way to put put the ropes
they said
so 97 what did you play look 81 okay n65
okay
maybe five
yep
created
it's like a she she did something
already little slightly suspicious now
and now it seems like buck is quite
comfortable you know with two bishops
let's go back let me see if we could do
something better
I was always under the impression you go
Bishop g5 in these positions so you can
put pressure on the night that was my
impression usually you bring the bishop
here to put pressure
I think castles then you go queen d3
and then you put the rooks on d1 and e1
with this setup
okay
so this should be a I'm not sure because
it looks like it's gonna be Lily was
wonderful so you Castle now what do you
like these
okay
I guess anymore
look everyone queen 85 okay
94 was Bishop before a consideration
because block is a very strong Bishop on
d4 did you head atop of maybe you know
trying to trade the bishop off
did you consider that
why not exchange like to Bishop well he
opponent his to bishops when opponent
has to bishops were we try to do usually
exchange one of the bishops so he lose
the to Bishop advantage but bishops are
very strong when they work together here
you play Bishop before you're trying to
exchange one of the bishops okay
so what happened
Oh
Aashish is white yeah Shishir is white
go ahead 595 okay attacking the Queen
okay
look SC
ass boy okay
ninety-seven
okay II five Wow
very interesting at the same time quite
sharp right sharp as well and it takes
your gonna go 96 I should she's taking
advantage of the fact that that night is
vulnerable and if capture occurred he
can take here and then take the
unprotected night on December
okay
after 85
he's late 27
ninety-six Prince's show okay
Queen c7 here okay
he tasty
eat tasty six I was expecting Fontes
ready to put the Queen
okay know what the Queen it's risky
thing to do you know so very very
surprised you take with this okay to the
Queen Wow that feels very dangerous
right it seems like you're walking
walking into a trouble here voluntarily
so what happened right at five yeah let
the fire attack in the Queen and again
if you take tonight can take the Queen
here so what happened
please
we knew six okay 90s Jason Knight takes
juice 7tm teaspoon ginger so on this
should be for Jay
26 of these pieces
here yes
yep
Ruby
do you wanna huh Nagi
beat
be fun
CBI's baby flood
why don't you take b3 here you are
concerned about your c4 plan right so
isn't it better to play something like
this that way you can continue playing
before a 4 B 5 and you have a nice
queenside majority when you're pushing
your pants wrong and also you're fixing
the pawn on g7 now though that one
cannot move because if it plays b5 you
will just simply take on Poisson now I
want to play B for a 4 and then b5 okay
B for a 4th
okay what happened
I would be too
yep b3
we're trying to get a Bishop on c5
correct
a g6
Ruby seven
thank you so okay
ninety-four
[ __ ] seasick
ninety-five
he ate take it pump yeah very nice now
when you know now you increase your
advantage to two ponds okay
yes
he could the knight f6 Knight takes f6
f6 yeah you're trading yeah you did that
okay
good thinking that's what I shoes did
also I'm not sure if I would have done
that that night on g8 didn't look very
very active I mean the night on g8 I
mean it's not a very good piece okay so
you could also play a move like Bishop
c5 here for example and still have a
very nice advantage okay you retain
retain the big advantage so here take
stakes then what happened
okay
Bishop b5
rook c5 super okay King yes
this your taste yuh-huhhh
Bishop g2
the mission tastes
Bishop g2 okay okay
jeez so what happened yesterday yeah
this should be winning should be not no
big problem to win this you know because
you have two extra pawns 94 huh they
trying to go this way
yeah okay
king of six
look see search check kf7
okay
Kady
kd5 root k 7'k Brooks III okay okay
keeping the King cut and ready to cross
here yeah this is this f4 pawn it's no
problem with just as long as we have
this yeah now you just push the pawns
yeah this was a good game Ashish good
game I mean in the opening I'm not sure
little bit you know the opening needs to
be discussed much more further you know
but I think attend you know when he you
really yeah I'm not sure this this moves
I'm not quite sure about but he five I'm
just surprised he didn't just take with
the pawn because now he can switch back
on the e-file and there are certain weak
squares now in your position okay the
Foursquare is weak for a for some it
squares in the position yeah
all right let's see we have a game from
Danielle Danielle Maya my cutie
yeah Maya and thank you for submitting
your game okay please tell a little bit
about yourself in the future when you
submit the game that'd be easier you
know tell your name maybe say your name
were you from your rating a little bit
more details so that way we can refer to
you enough we assume your name you know
it's what your account is but anyway
just introduce yourself a little bit you
know you're you know if you're young
Claire you can mention your age you know
I'm 10 years old you know and then
submit your game and you can mention
where did this game was played if it's a
tournament game so Danielle against talk
wasabi we we're not sure but this looks
like this is played in chess club chess
which is not coming yes okay f5
everybody what is the name of this
opening should be lots of hands here
what is the name of this which one
no it's got a very specific name yes yes
the Dutch defense correct Dutch defense
and this is very popular about couple of
years ago you had Carlsen playing this
Nakamura playing these comps keep
playing this cousin lost the game and me
I haven't seen him play dodge since then
he lost the game too Radek boy taschek
in a chorus tournament Tata Steel
tournament and he lost to him in this ok
Bishop f4 interesting approach not
really playing any of the main lines
with c4 Knight f3 g3 this is my favorite
move to be honest I don't know if it's
gonna transpose later but I quite like
this move it's a very direct idea very
direct idea saying you know I wanna play
this move before I'm sorry d5 is my game
against gata Kamsky if you remember 2014
US Championship it's my game in 2014 so
he played here I played here got I went
here I went here and it's a game it's I
got a pretty nice position and I ended
up drawing the game it was a bit
disappointing at some point I had
something like 50 minute advantage on
the clock because I knew the opening
very well and he was so familiar with
the idea so I had a really pleasant
position ok so maybe at some point I can
show you that game ok so that's
basically what you do but Bishop before
I'm not sure how good this move is
because it's bitter it's unclear right I
mean what is the bishop doing on f4
I mean we don't know yes
there may very well might be no he's
trying to play the London or a young
student mentioned maybe possibly yes
it's just bit strange to do this against
the Dutch
so d6 makes sense right to shut down the
Bishop Knight f3 III h3 h3 is a typical
move when your Bishop on a 4 because you
want to have this shelter for the bishop
to go to on h2 they should be 7
see three yes correct gets London
haven't seen this too often but I mean I
mean at the same time white setup is
it's gotta be suspicious Amina weakening
weakening although yeah it's possible
but it is it's it's important to
understand in chess weaknesses weak
squares weak which part move weakens the
position in general every part move
weakens the position you should know
that but here we just see a lot of holes
you know a lot of light square holes we
see in the position so I'm not really
liking what I see here from block here
so there should be 397 wait a minute
that's just a free pawn so and in chess
it's very important to remember when you
make them when opponent makes the move
what is the very first thing you need to
do Ashish what is the very first thing
you need to do when opponent makes the
move anybody you playing doesn't matter
GM or a beginner any level what is the
first thing you do yes what is he
threatening what is the idea behind his
move did you guys ask yourself that
question very important you do that when
you play when you get stronger and
stronger at the higher level we don't
think that way all the time but at the
moment it's a good way to think okay
until you reach to you know master you
know in higher levels every time I put
it makes a move you stop and think say
what is it reading what is the idea
behind this move a black obviously
didn't do that and thank you very much
for the pawn and that is a very
important part because now the King is
gonna be a weak
you should beat me I'm not sure when you
have active move what you should do play
yeah and I look at this idea
boom meat would even look at that idea
night jumps in check 96 very quickly you
know you can turn this thing around okay
very quickly
okay
so he took he just went back white is
happy who owned upon before
non-aggressive do you see - okay well
yeah just raise your hand only very good
so here you have an option here you need
to protect that pond so you can protect
it with the Queen which he did I don't
like to ask where and see - that was
chosen you know I would have liked to
put the Queen on e - here but our young
student here mentioned something else
which piece is more natural to develop
eh yes perfect Knight goes to D to
developing protecting the center I mean
and that's just so much more comfortable
it's so much more comfortable so much
easier okay
g7 consoles g5 ok this approach I'm not
sure if it's very good do you think why
should be so direct attacking or he
should try to finish his development
what you should do
he should try to finish his development
first okay Knight h5 yeah this is yeah
Knight bTW - is a better move here for
sure
you should g6 okay I don't think this
works
yeah I think later with the white pieces
got very excited about the prospects of
the attack but attack could have been
simply defended by a move Queen e8 and
now I'm not so clear what to do it looks
like this attack is just gonna simply
fizzle out because you go here eliminate
I mean when peace is not developed what
are you gonna mate with
so very important to develop here okay
Danielle you have to develop your pieces
before you to attack it worked in this
game but against stronger opponent you
wouldn't have worked a tank by the way
there is a very important in between
move here
no one has swooshing souq right who can
find the solution so here the white mist
white can probably win this if he finds
that swooshing souk do you see that idea
Adak oh yeah 95 and now you threaten
this
now you're threatened to make okay
and if you move the rook just to escape
check
check
winning the Queen and the game
yeah so here again development would
have been better thanks
little later but still very effective so
it was very important moment here to you
know to stop this 95 ideas so white
should have played a move Queen to d8
exchanging the Queens that would have
been a very important movement way and
exchange the Queens but he didn't do
that it took
here
matter of six
fix
well I think this is very strong no 96
no need to capture back better just set
up a mating threat now with threatened
mate on g7 and attack the Queen
that teammate or the Quinn
2e 6
Queeny 8 May 12
it's funny it's not so over if he plays
this move
I mean it's might be bad but so I think
if take for the Queen
it's not this hanging so in 94
well name I'm not even quite sure if
this position is that bad
so okay six because now the threat is
checked the threat is this
what to do
to be checkers coming up
very very very tough
despite being down three pounds I think
I would have choose black here because
it's I thought you tried to develop it's
gonna backfire you know [ __ ] is just
very very active here g2 is hanging and
two hands look the 80s threatens
comes in and starts taking some pawns
and again despite being down material
it's more comfortable to play this with
the black pieces okay
okay let's take a look at one more game
submitted so the players the person who
spent as Sean Eric Sean Eric submits the
game that he lost let's see alright Sean
let's take a look d 4 d 6 ok again we
see a bishop fo what's going on here
everybody love in the London London
system London it was the capital of the
last year's you know the World
Championship you know you know the big
match was there the chess city and then
London chest classic was their end of
the years there was a lot of chess in
the month of November December a lot of
people are actually going there visiting
so um c6 played here 95 it seemed so
much really not 25 to attack the center
and question that Bishop know it's such
a natural thing to do here c6 c3
conservative very conservative Knight f3
g6 Bishop d3 Bishop d7 9b d to castle
castle Queen c7 yeah now black still
wants to play 5 but Queen b3
we'll be three here
to move it's a possibility there are
other moves to play here a four before
Queen b3 I'm not sure if it's optimal I
probably would have liked to see a move
like a ch3 here played a ch3 so if a
five I can talk in the bishop on h2 this
is probably what I would have liked to
see okay
23:05 the stakes
Bishop takes if I what's happening here
so looks like clear with the white
pieces they recounted correctly here you
always need to have one more extra piece
attacking something then the defenders
are so if you're attacking it twice is
defended twice you cannot take it you
need to be attacking it three times one
more extra time than the defender in
order to take okay but here we see the
player with the white piece is taking
upon and that just that just drops a
piece and then night when here he
dropped another piece and that's game
over right ish so this was a tough one
okay
I don't think we need to go further here
it's down to pieces you're not gonna
save the game you think good opponent so
I mean this is reasonable I mean not my
favorite setup for white but again
London players they like to get this set
up you know but you know if you do this
you better play h3 and look for
possibilities to get some space on this
side of the board a 45 but I think just
he just simply forgot the count and then
after that it was in in chess sometimes
you make one really bad move and then
that leads to more mistakes and then
another mistake occurred and the game is
over there is no coming back after this
now okay let's take a look at one more
game the last one and then I have a
couple of positions for you to work on
so let's see here this is a club staff
member Perry Coulson played as white
against a much higher rated player on Li
Ches how many people here play on LI or
Li Ches
Wow quite a few players excellent yeah
it's it's this new thing it's been
around what like let's say two years now
year and a half something like that so
it's and it's taking over it's quite
popular it's free and you know they even
have Magnus Carlsen play there sometimes
and I think he's got a couple of
accounts one of his accounts is think a
doctor or a doctor or mr. doctor doctor
drunken steam
so and he plays like a drunk openings
there yeah he plays like yeah
it plays f3 king of two then comes back
you know like he you know so anyway so
this is Carrie who works at the clock
and we all know Perry and so Perry if
you're watching we are non Eliza your
game now against Barbosa
alright 93 so we have a Queens gambit
declined because it was not captured it
was declined they okay by this move so
now I have three knife 693 a six it's
interesting that this is what Magnus
cause in place you know like blitz and
Rapids it takes takes Bishop f4 we
should be six Bishop g3 castles Queen c2
Rocky III bishop f8 okay that's very
strange when you have it developed piece
by going back on f8 I'm not sure what's
the point of the move but you're just
simply undeveloped in it okay so don't
do that basically also b5 a parry goes
90 to 90 T is okay but did white finish
is development not yet right so maybe it
would make sense to get this out
Brooke a c1 perhaps Brooke a c1 rook f
d1
we get away with 96 nice yeah yeah 95 is
a very very attractive move - excellent
move yeah yeah now this did this would
be a really neat yeah if this is somehow
allowed they know this would just be
wonderful not for white look at that now
we learn again wait what sorry now we
learned that every pond move that's what
creates weaknesses with square so you
have to be very careful with the pond
nose okay don't just make a pond move
thing it's just gonna be okay your every
pawn push it's gotta make sense gotta
have an idea okay every pawn move every
pawn idea it's gotta make sense okay you
cannot just do it because you feel like
you gotta do it you know I mean very
important to remember you ninety-five a
quiet light I think this should be seven
then you want to play f4
wait Oh oh yeah
94 I already is 95 sorry
so I thought you say 95 this is very
interesting okay takes takes takes but
this is 96 years before this generally
this kind of tactics sometimes they work
sometimes they work but normally you
need to have a king in the middle
normally or just to work you know but I
actually like this you know because I
like this very very much you know
because of 96 ideas and I like this very
much so I think this is just absolutely
wonderful 96 dropping the Queen so if he
plays Bishop e7 then I go I like f4 okay
92 Bishop d6 we see six attacking the
rook Felix e5 need to be played here you
know I feel like c5 you need to prevent
this entrances of the Queen
you should be six Queen c6 by the way
one thing I want to mention to everybody
here and also our YouTube audience game
analysis is one of the most important
things any player should do that's where
you improve the most when you play the
games and analyze them afterwards
ideally you analyze them with a coach a
person who will tell you the moves but
if you don't have a coach then you can
analyze using some of the engines okay
engines will just point out the moves
they won't tell you why you do this move
but of this they'll give you an idea
where which direction to go to I
personally I have you know many students
that I train online and in-person here
in st. Louis so it's very important the
first thing I do when they finish the
tournament next lesson I'll ask them to
bring their score sheets or if they put
a computer in a computer this so that's
the very first thing we do game analysis
you should not play another tournament
until you analyze the previous
tournament games in Soviet chess school
it was actually they would really forbid
the students from playing any other
tournaments until they really deeply
analyzed all the games they played
because if you don't analyze your games
let's imagine you just keep playing you
never analyzed your games for like for a
couple of months similar mistakes you're
gonna make made one mistake in this
tournament you're gonna make a similar
mistakes opening mistake or ideas so
that's five analyze your games it's
really really big part will be for your
improvement ninety-six
we should be seven now going back okay
maybe we should be six should have been
played here first see 895 wow did you
guys see how Perry got exchanged she
went here I wants to go some 96 ideas
takes now if Knight captures any of the
Knights Bishop d6 is hanging so this is
hanging and if Queen takes which happen
in the game that run into a powerful
Bishop f5 attacking the Queen and the
rook winning material and now look at
that nice here yeah but then then
there's a nice in-between check check
takes it just down a piece so you can't
unfortunately because of that in between
check so takes let's just quickly look
at the conversion oh wait
it took rook c5 at least back should
retreat with a queen and okay he's
losing but this is just down the rook
and down exchange okay so this we don't
really need to analyze this position
this you know you should be able to win
this no problem okay
so game analysis very important okay
please very important okay let's do one
a very important study position for you
if you familiar with it please raise
your hand
don't say the moves because I'm sure
there will be some players who are not
familiar with this study
illegal position all right now it's
legal how many people know this position
raise your hand because I might have
shown this before so we have one two
students who familiar okay double check
go through down sir double check all the
moves because there are three different
moves black can play so there is
something you can definitely review
sorry it's white to play and win white
to play and win again encourage to send
your games to info at st. Louis Chess
Club org again in in the beginning of
your game just introduce yourself your
name you know where you live and where
the game was played so the for the game
analysis will know who whose game we're
analyzing we don't have to guess the
name of easier live it okay
give you two more minutes two more
minutes okay they're going to look at
this position two more minutes
okay please raise your hand if you know
the first month small hint for you maybe
not so small but you have to put black
king in a soup sabang okay so you got
what you want it you want to force his
queen to move if his queen needs to move
then we get some ideas Adi
Bravo that puts his king in the souq and
if he does a check like this you can go
b8 night look at that you can probably
put a queen - but I like night better
because it's checkmate so he has to
sacrifice and now how you take to avoid
the still mate Queen take and now he
goes here he just made okay with the
king and queen so he's not gonna do that
so he's got one two three four options
okay four options four possibilities so
what do we do four options for
possibilities
or 25 first first things first Ashish
Adi
and if it takes
thank you very much okay
so that's out
Queen f3
dicks
check jingles away take got it
if it goes here now what do you do
their queen what queen a tree Bravo
again deflection same idea same
mechanism works here okay deflection and
now we go down to the most important
move in h1 the same idea might not work
here
I fish addict
yeah Wow
it
that's it winning the Queen and if he
goes here
and if he goes here
so
I mean in this line
raise your hands please the winning move
is should be more hands I see only few
yes Bravo
look at that move long-range move okay
long-range move you have to spy you
always have to look at the whole 64
squares when you claim she has never be
focused on one area of the board the
whole 64 squares needs to be observed
now check he has to take now he has to
take
check
okay
excellent
any questions yeah this is a very nice
study it's a classical study okay I also
recommend you guys work on studies and
this will help you to with your
imagination we see many different
patterns you know like you put the king
in a stalemate situation then he has to
start moving the Queen okay so remember
that those are very very important
things to do okay thank you everybody
for attending this class we're gonna
take a little break we'll have one more
class after this if you have time stick
around for the next class and that class
has got a very nice interesting name
chess in the Romantic era okay so we're
gonna look at some romantic chess games
okay see you in a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]